les inspecteurs de la police régionale
de Yorki aussi de l'Unité des Enquêtes
spéciales sont allés et venues toute la
journée aujourd'hui devant cet immeuble
il tente de comprendre comment
exactement 6 personnes sont mortes ici
dans la soirée dimanche
le chef de la police
raconte cela avait été tué par balle
dans trois appartements différents un
drame qui a causé une onde de choc dans
le voisinage
le coronaire ne révèle pas pour le
moment l'identité des victimes mais la
police dit qu'il s'agit de trois hommes
et deux femmes trois de ces personnes
faisaient partie du conseil
d'administration de l'immeuble le
suspect qui a été tué dans une
confrontation avec la police a été
identifié comme Francesco Vili un
résident de l'immeuble âgé de 73 ans
selon le témoignage de plusieurs de ses
voisins il était un conflit avec le
conseil d'administration de l'immeuble
depuis des années en raison de
réparation que celui-ci aurait refusé de
payer et plusieurs de ses propres
publications sur les réseaux sociaux en
témoignent
ce voisin qui connaissait bien le
suspect évoque la possibilité de
problèmes de santé mentale lui qui a
fait partie du conseil d'administration
pendant un an dit qu'il a essayé de
l'aider
nous nous sentions tous menacés
spéciales qui se penchent sur tous les
cas où des personnes perdent la vie dans
une intervention policière continue
leurs enquêtes ici miradjukic